today I'm thrilled to announce our next  step in the journey to make gaming more  accessible project Leonardo  our code name for a new PS5  accessibility controller kit that will  allow players with disabilities to play  more easily  more comfortably and for longer periods  project Leonardo is highly customizable  thank you and works out of the box  providing a robust kit of swappable  components and a suite of software  options on PS5  it's a true canvas that enables many  gamers with disabilities to craft their  own play experience  it can be used as a standalone  controller  or paired with a second project Leonardo  controller or a dual sense wireless  controller  we'd like to thank wonderful  organizations like ablegamers special  effect  Stack Up and several other accessibility  experts who are supporting us on this  journey